if bullets came out of this gun it was
not a prop gun it was a real gun that
was being used as a prop in the movie
a startling new report claims that russ
crew members took guns from the new
mexico set including the one that killed
cinematographer helena hutchins to shoot
at beer cans with real ammo to pass the
time that of course could explain why a
live round was in alex's gun the type of
gun that they were using was most likely
a single action gun
e.t spoke today with firearms expert
steve wolf who showed us the difference
between bullets and blanks and just how
easy it is to check a revolver when you
rotate through the cylinders
you make sure that there's nothing in
them
and if there is something in them and
you want to see what it is you push the
ejector rod here
to pop it out
and take a look at it so yep that that's
that's a blank that's what i
intended to be there and then you can
put it back in and then you can close
that up and proceed with your shot
another revelation russ assistant
director dave halls had prior safety
issues
he's about to check the gun she's
responsible for this
we're told halls who allegedly handed
alec the gun was fired from the set of
another movie freedom's path in 2019 the
production behind it tells us it
happened after a crew member suffered a
minor injury when a gun was unexpectedly
discharged the fact that someone had
safety red flags against them was
absolutely a reason to pass on them
armorer hana gutierrez reid this was
only her second film job police say she
prepared the gun before halls handed it
to alec by all means i'm still learning
it doesn't matter how many rules you
have if you don't have the knowledge and
experience to follow them
the movie's gaffer meanwhile posted this
pic of helena inside the church where
she was shot calling it the last photo
with her on set
so what's alex's role in the tragedy as
the producer of the film malik has
ultimate responsibility for all of the
safety he's responsible for hiring
people who have the experience to know
how to do it properly we were rehearsing
and it went off
per the search warrant director joel
souza told authorities alec was
practicing pointing the revolver towards
the camera lens
he is responsible to know
that you don't point guns at people
unless you want to put bullets in them
no charges have been filed but a source
tells e.t the actor is still processing
the accident it is to be expected no
matter how the evidence falls out he
will feel a sense of self-blame
oftentimes for months or years
afterwards clinical psychologist dr
romini der vasila says alec's support of
helena's family is critical this is
something that feels right to the people
involved and that it is helping with the
healing i think what's absolutely
critical is that the people watching the
story not judge it alec may also be
taking a step back friday's expected
release of a documentary he narrated
flint who can you trust has been
indefinitely postponed because this is
in the public eye there's a lot of
rumor and innuendo and questions and all
of those things make the grief so much
more complicated this is going to leave
an echo that goes through their entire
life
you